[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you can follow ian rappaport the nfl
network insider ian rappaport on twitter
at rap sheet and uh ian kind enough to
join us this morning good morning ian
let me start with our poll question
russell wilson will be the quarterback
of the
seahawks raiders cowboys bears saints at
the start of next season
i would say probably the seahawks i mean
it's not impossible
i think one thing we've learned in the
nfl this year is that quarterback trades
massive quarterback trades the kind that
we used to scoff at years ago
they can happen i mean it's slowly
becoming a little more like the nba
where people aren't afraid to take on
dead money they're not afraid to make a
splash they're not afraid to
take a risk i mean these things have now
happened so
at least this conversation that we're
having now is not fake
whereas like four years ago i would have
been like come on dan
um but my guess is the seahawks for a
couple reasons
one 40 million dollar cap hit for a team
that is
contending every single year is a lot
and then let's just play it out let's
say it's the raiders
and derek carr is in the trade so then
it's 40 million dollars for russell
wilson in a
you know dead cap hit 25 million dollars
for derek carr
that's 65 million dollars allocated to
the quarterback position
that's a lot the other thing is pete
carroll is 70 years old
he does not want to rebuild so if you're
trading russell wilson you told me you
wanted to
start the dynasty again and rebuild i'd
say cool that actually would make some
sense
pete carroll doesn't want to do that a
trade doesn't make sense
for any party how did we get to this
point with seattle
well i think it was slowly building
probably from like week eight or nine
when seattle's offense went from letting
russ cook to
whatever it was we saw at the end of the
year you know he started turning it over
they kind of started focusing on running
the ball to stop him from turning it
over and go back to the brandon football
that had made seattle famous
and i don't think russell wilson liked
that he wanted to cook he wanted to get
the mvp votes he wanted to
be the kind of superstar quarterback
that
he is and that we see other quarter like
aaron rod you know the packers run the
ball with aaron rodgers but rogers is
the star the running game is not the
star right
um and that was a philosophical
difference and the fact that
they had to play the season out and it
didn't kind of get resolved during the
season
only led to this little you know kind of
mini war of words or whatever you'd call
it now he was involved
in the picking of the offensive
coordinator that was good um
but they still got a lot of work to do
to kind of get everyone on the same page
here
but when he came on the show a couple of
weeks ago
you've been around russ he doesn't open
the door and
and really answer things honestly and
you know everything is go hawks and he
wants to tell you all the things that
you
he thinks you want to hear he opened the
door for me
i and i don't know if it was off of
going to the super bowl he looked
miserable
he's watching mahomes and brady and
going
why am i not playing in another another
super bowl
but do you think that it was
orchestrated on his part
to allow me to ask those questions um
i wondered about that uh it was an
eye-opening interview i will say that
like when i
i think i first saw the clips on twitter
and i'm like
what is happening here i had to go and
kind of click which
you know obviously for you like you're
doing an interview and someone has to go
from twitter to that artwork and i find
this
that's a that's a great interview i
thought the whole thing was eye-opening
i started to get a sense before the
super bowl that something was happening
like i got wind of
teams calling the seahawks about russell
and i reported it
on our pregame shirt show before the
super bowl
and usually you report something like
that and you get a lot of pushback don't
say anything don't
stir it up we don't need that out there
i didn't quite get that
it was more like well it's true so you
happen to find out about it like
okay and that was interesting to me and
then
he kind of goes on this media tour for
man of the year
goes on your show and a couple others
and uh he doesn't shy away from the fact
that he's frustrated he doesn't like to
get hit
which i don't either i get it um i think
it's time where he's like you know what
i'm taking ownership of myself my career
my team
i want this to get better uh and in a
way i don't blame them
but it just makes it a little messy when
that happens but if you're seattle do
you reach out to the bears
the cowboys the saints the raiders the
doors open
yeah the doors open but i mean the
reality is you have russell wilson if
you want to trade him you could trade
him in like two seconds right like
everybody would want russell wilson
that's not the problem trading him is
easy you could get
three ones two ones and a great player
and another good player like
you could get a great package for wes
wilson that's easy john schneider is the
master he could do it in two phone calls
um the problem is who do you replace him
with and i think that's the problem for
everyone like
let's say like the houston texans i
don't think they're trading deshaun
watson
but let's say they do fine you get a lot
of draft picks
who is actually your quarterback for
seattle
you know you trade russell wilson unless
you're
taking someone of his caliber and
putting him in there
you are automatically rebuilding so how
does that actually benefit the seahawks
that's the real question
and i can't help but think of jerry
jones today
or yesterday when he saw this list that
came out and you know jerry loves
shiny new objects and it gives him a
little leverage i guess with dak
prescott
whether he uses that or not like the
feasibility of the cowboys
kicking the tires on russell wilson is
what
uh not not very feasible to me the
cowboys situation is very very easy
sign dak prescott he is one of the best
young quarterbacks in the nfl
he actually got more valuable when he
hurt his ankle
because the team was not good like i see
it's crazy to me it's always been crazy
to me when i saw people argue that
carson wentz
was better than dak prescott it's like
it's almost like what am i watching
right like to me it was obvious that dak
was
where he was and carson was going the
wrong way which i think has been pretty
clear now
but it'd always be like what are people
saying like how are they missing this
and i kind of feel like that with dak
too like
he's a rising young quarterback who's
actually getting better he's a great
person
rehab's going well it's going to be
expensive to sign him because yeah it's
expensive to sign quarterbacks
but the price is only going up and i'll
say this let's just say
god forbid the cowboys don't sign dak
prescott
by march 9 when they tag him or by july
15th
he'll be a free agent next year he will
make all of the money
and by then it's possible he leaves the
cowboys
and again how does that benefit dallas
talking to ian rappaport the nfl network
insider
did did desean watson have a
face-to-face
with his coach or a phone call with
david culley uh it was not face to face
okay uh it was either a phone call or
could have been zoom there's like a
could have been facetime could have been
skype you know
there's a lot of different i don't think
it was rotary phone um
but i it was either phone call or some
sort of
face-to-face interaction type deal it
didn't sound like it was much
desean watson from what i understand
always planned to do this
out of respect for david culley who at
65 years old
basically got his lifetime dream of
being a head coach in the nfl
i never thought it would change anything
and it hasn't changed anything he's
where he is
the texans are where they are and if
they trade him which i got my doubts
right now like it's not going to be
anytime soon yeah i wondered i i thought
carson once would eventually get traded
i didn't think desean watson would get
traded
but here's wentz who wanted out of
philadelphia and got traded
and deshawn watson wants out but i also
wonder about the timing of this ian
because at some point these teams will
move on and go
all right if he's not available then
we'll look at free agents or we'll look
at the draft
i if if i'm the texans i just say we're
open for business like the lions did
with matthew stafford
come on down give us your best offer and
we'll move forward
that makes sense yeah it it does if
you're the texans and you're okay not
having desean watts
like he's one of the best young
quarterbacks in the nfl and even though
there's this
sort of business personal thing going on
he is a great person high character
quarterback right so
why would you ever want to trade him
like whatever price they could give
unless it's the jaguars or like maybe
the jets in some sort of package maybe
you know replacing deshaun watson is
hard or
impossible unless you hit the lottery
which they already did with watson
the timing is really interesting because
usually
you say all right like what's the what's
the deadline all right we need to know
by free agency all right we need to know
about the draft
desean watson is so good and so
valuable that he actually doesn't where
he is in the market doesn't matter like
they could say in
july 25th or something okay fine we'll
trade him and you would have teams ready
to offer multiple first-round picks
for one of the best quarterbacks in the
nfl like i don't think the market
affects his value if the texans ever
decided to trade it
i just don't understand what happened
you know he had that emotional press
conference he was crying he thanked
everybody this was great
what did he find out you know i know
that you know you trade hopkins
uh but he they had traded hopkins then
he got his contract extension i think so
what did he all of a sudden realize that
made him go
this is not the place i want to be yeah
i mean i i think it
when you have a problem with the owner
that is
tough to overcome and it's it's all in a
weird situation right because you have
nicosia or gm
in there you have david culley the head
coach watson doesn't have a problem with
either
and so they have been trying to kind of
make it right
but what's unfortunate is at this point
there has not been anything they could
do to change his mind because they're
not even involved
it's the owner it's the owner promising
you know
trading his best receiver without
telling and he found out on twitter
and then saying he would be involved in
the process
of hiring the gm just be involved like
just let him know
maybe talk some people and then he finds
out on twitter
i think that's something that to him has
been really hard to overcome and
as of i mean i've talked to people on
all sides of this i honestly don't know
what fixes this
i thought drew brees was going to take
this week to have his
going away party like he had the week to
himself
very quiet with drew brees what do you
think
well today's not over yet now you know
usually you'd say you wouldn't want to
do it on friday because the saturday
papers but i mean
you know papers or so i don't know if
people think like that anymore
could be today he's retiring drew brees
is retiring he's going to have an
awesome job in our world next year he's
going to make a lot of money are you
guaranteeing drew brees is retiring
yes he's retiring and the reason i know
that is because one he's retiring
but two they took his salary they took
it all the way down to the minimum
drew brees is not gonna play for one
million dollars next year
he's not going to play for the veteran
minimum he's also just not going to play
so you know maybe he's waiting for his
time maybe he wanted to kind of let it
breathe a little bit
i don't know but he is retiring good to
talk to you ian have a good weekend we
appreciate your time as always
awesome thanks for having me man take
care that's uh ian rappaport nfl network
insider